now playing i'm daniel dwyer joined by
i'm andy bauman hey what's up andy where
am i looking camera hey what's up guys
do you have the need dude
the need for video games nope not for
search no that's not that's a little bit
weird yeah chroma keyboard wrong color
can for the green screen see-through
[ __ ] uh we're here with need for
speed which is uh not out until next
week um scott butterworth is doing the
review for gamespot.com however i have
ea access on my xbox one account which
means that i can play the game for free
for 10 hours yeah i've been playing for
probably an hour so we've got okay hurry
we've got nine hours tick-tock andy show
me this video game all right i'll talk
real fast so we can say here's the
subaru brz i bought uh at the beginning
of the game uh maybe put a new hood on
it because you can customize stuff okay
um so how much have you played so far
like only like an hour yeah only the
very initial like i saw a party and then
they were like hey you just did a cool
drift pound and then they're like come
to the garage and then they're like race
me the thing and then that's it and now
i got a car and then all these
hardpoints are locked right so okay i
got to do stuff before i can actually
customize i gotta do missions but i
could but i did buy a few parts i bought
some new brakes because that's always
good about new tires because you
definitely need new tires and of course
a new exhaust because that's the easiest
way to get more horsepower and and make
your neighbors hate you yeah uh or set
up some car launches so it's fun
your actual subaru does do that right it
does i hear little chirps when i go by
sometimes like i'm like oh
these are all locked though behind these
levels and i'm only level one level this
needs level 15 this needs level 35 44 so
it's like okay 44 wow okay so that's
quite a night time
it looks like it's shot on a camera
which i love like because all the lights
flare out and it looks really cool at
nighttime so i don't know
do you remember when it was originally
shown the the like crazy
cell phone like footage yeah dude the
camera would like when you did a drift
like you go like that basically and like
yeah
apparently it's not it's not doing this
it doesn't do that yeah that was maybe a
bit too much um so it looks pretty
though yeah we're playing on xbox one
obviously xbox one cause that's where
you got your ea access that's the only
place you can get you yeah that's true
crash into stuff i want to see some dude
you don't want to mess up your swing
right you're already married to not
injuring it ever yeah it doesn't seem
like there's very much damage to it
that's some good rain effects right yeah
that frostbite edge to it you know and
this isn't the third this is 30 frames a
second though this is oh yeah it totally
doesn't just in case you're wondering
internet streamers this is not running
at 60 but i don't have nitrous yet but
i'll expand the button anyway
uh here's the thing i don't know where
i'm going cool
uh well there's a marker over there i
know i'm trying to get there but it
looks like it's off the map oh yeah so
apparently this game is four different
like boras but they're all available
right from the off yeah so let's go here
also see that other driver you have
there yeah i think you can straight up
just go up and like race them
like
so
see what happens god
is coming to maybe he's coming to me
maybe he is route
you'd think but with only nine hours we
didn't want to waste any time right
exactly but now we are just wasting all
the time all right jump back in there
maybe the raids conditions uh there's
gonna try and do those the ones you kind
of run into as well around the place
which are just in the world and then
there's all the like this thing here for
instance and then there's
the world is not very populated by no
general traffic no i talked to them
about that i was like where are all the
other people in this world apparently
that's a real good reason to set the
game during the night time yeah because
everyone's asleep which i guess is
accurate to street racing people tend
not to do it during like commuter hours
i guess
yeah but yeah at least you're
at least at least there's some at least
not getting away let's say that yeah
that's better
on the missions they're going to have
yeah i wonder how much they do actually
i sure wish my navigation system worked
where you go so where's where's your
point it's down there no to your right
it's over there this is so far away
it's just on the highway it's good all
right so
what's what's x what's speed wall
okay no speed wall is just you're like
just like the leaderboard or something
yeah all right so you set a navigation
point so hit b
to go back no just hit it and then go
away from it
oh teleport what was that roof no no
okay so go teleport to it or you can set
a roof okay so that's it that is a
little bit of an not intuitive system
though no
like why can't you just do it like every
other game and it just gives you a thing
like a
so i guess you can just fast travel
anywhere you want oh donuts are a tasty
way to get ripped that's uh that's true
i wonder if you could like set up your
controller to just keep donuting all
night
you've come back and your car's running
on steel here we go
horses for courses
you gotta run that circuit race so spike
is like the first guard to me he was
super stoked for some reason that you
came to town okay like you did something
and he was like oh my god this guy's
great so
you really want to be friends
spike and then he's going to take it all
the events
um there's no manual shift
you don't even have an option oh right
it's like the first
so it's twice
arcadius thing in that respect yeah this
is a this is the burn need for speed
realm not the
forza
because that's what that's where you do
once you're driving right you prefer the
simulation
the forza engine are just so good at
driving
that's what i like
so you're supposed to be beating spike
yeah i think i'm just supposed to pass
like take that spike um
it doesn't seem to be a lot of penalties
for coming in the corners fast
so you can turn no whoa no problem
he's the second man
all right check point to checkpoint so
we can confirm need for speed has
checkpoint races sporty tech wise in
this race dude look at all that oreo
getting
oh man i can't let him pass me come on
16 almost halfway
ghost
your car's license plate is named after
the developer of this game
i like it i guess it's better than ea
being your
license plate
i wonder if the customization allows you
to change that as well we know you can
do everything from like we'll get into
it a little bit like tuning your brakes
and tuning your yeah i need to get some
a higher level so i can unlock some of
that stuff
my exhaust is apparently giving me some
good advantages right
i know this is super early on but it
doesn't really feel like you're racing
spike so much as there's a lot of rubber
banding happening
yeah he's guessing what's happening yeah
like he's going ahead and then you're
going ahead and then
it's not exactly like you're racing for
position but then it is early so they're
probably just trying to
kind of easy them yeah
lucky just slowing down there a little
bit yeah
spike is just
oh i forgot to answer the phone oops
manu is ringing you get a lot of phone
calls did you see manu ringing there
yeah i missed it too late he'll come
back he's a style guy so there's
different people
in this so they're they're actually real
worlds like people like like i know ken
block ken block is in there so you might
get your gymkhana on at some stage oh
spy you just kill that lady dude i'm not
cool wow wait was there someone in the
car yeah you can see people in the cars
at least one person
no child in the back
baby on board
um yeah so
they have a basically like people who
are
there are missions for like the speed
people and missions for the
style people admissions for the
you know i don't know
yeah so
man who was calling up there to tell you
all about tricking out your car and you
just [ __ ] ghosted it you didn't even
listen i was in a race you know
you won
that was easy you just got four thousand
dollars for that all right i want to go
buy stuff boys i'm on new brakes are we
in the wrong line of work
she's got four grand dude all you have
to do is crash into that
person
should we go street race
if we get four grand
apparently spike's a trust funder
they've already set that up in the plot
is he actually yeah well that's what it
says so his dad probably cuts him off at
some point because he does something oh
we're on a phone call now i don't know
what he's saying okay
well spike is we're chilling okay all
about speed yeah spike speed
all right you got a new mission yeah go
talk to spike
whoa
yeah you like that weird 180
yeah
okay let's go back into the thing here
so which one which one's spike then
spike is green all right man who's
yellow amy just do an amy build yeah
let's go to amy she's a build i don't
know what that means but
click route
yeah teleport do right this time see
what happens yeah
so you so you hit over uh left and right
to get those options which is really
weird it doesn't tell you to
that was a hot tip
that one's hot tip number one
just the tips with andy baumann we gotta
lock in the camera it's a weird view
see if i can play the way
the way ghost intended lots of bands
vans do drive around at night
we can't yeah
but they deliver newspapers and
people's
personal whoa oh whoa whoa okay here we
go
here we go you know who also drives
around a nice police 5-0
all right you got three you gotta you're
gonna get a rest drive away drive away
hold on i better do a hot okay no
you're fine it's five and get away get
away
he's gonna arrest you all right let's
get out of here you're [ __ ] burnout
13 seconds
your total fight is at 725
wow it's going up huh
i mean at this stage you think they just
arrest you they will be finding you but
he's right on my butt
that's it just we're going he's also
driving the wrong way down there
oh yeah he's tight he's right there yeah
these knight cops don't give an f
okay your total fight is 940 now
so i think you can just stop and pay the
fine yeah but don't just keep going
no [ __ ] it this is this is a night
racing baby
what if you go into debt
to watch into debt like police debt or
something well you've only got like i
got like six thousand yeah so i mean
you're one-sixth of the way there
oh no
this is reckless police right you think
at this stage they pull back and call
the
like the support helicopter unit right
okay you are one thousand two hundred
ninety dollars now
i need to do something like wait where
are you going because since i'm on the
highway oh maybe oh [ __ ] you didn't pull
down
so you're in cooldown modes you gotta go
four seconds
three seconds
you would have had to pay fourteen
hundred dollars problem but instead you
got rewarded with rep for being a piece
of crap
and not caring about wider society well
done hey i'm a street racer i guess it's
night time there's not that many
civilians around right yeah make your
own roads man
this is the worst time
full of the jump
this is a really crazy google maps
that's just like
yolos wagons google maps
apple maps 1.0 yeah this is the special
one you subscribe to it gives you all
the shortcuts
it tells you where all the cops are
boom
destruction you just got rap
just this is like skateboarding man
you've got rep for just knocking over
some cones can we help rubble man i'm
getting it forever
all right
where's she out you're almost there i
want to see a hot fmv because oh yeah
fmp is good right there's lots of yeah i
mean it's
i'm impressed with with it
um from like a technical as a camera
person
it's pretty [ __ ] cool how they did it
all right so we're close enough what's
this ladies name again but it's also
super [ __ ] awkward this is amy
uh master the hero in the chat says in
uh rivals the cops were ruthless yeah
and this one not so much right now but
maybe they're gonna be a little bit
easier no i don't think we're going to
see a cutscene let's get it
for a while
until we do some of these rep missions
apparently the cutscenes involve a lot
of people rushing into rooms and then
rushing out of rooms whoa
and you kicking along no problem light
poles
please concernable while i'm racing
i'm going
yeah this is on it's not early access
it's on ea access which is a different
it's not like
no this is a full this is the finished
game it's just i got to play it for 10
hours because i'm on a access um
so
yeah um yoshimitsu 1984 asking what need
for speed is this oh uh frostbite engine
no it's just need for speed yeah 2015 is
that what they're going to call it do
you think
sometimes that's what happens with games
that just drop any sort of
subtitle prince of persian tomb raider
yeah so they've just called this one
need for speed
supra
oh man look at jc pepino all right
you're gonna get
whoa carla she's getting so much rep for
that right
now i thought i upgraded that
i'm not going to even strip you're not
really slip streaming anymore but it was
giving you
can hear that
i wonder how much money you're going to
earn for this one oh baby i mean if that
was one person you got four brands then
this should be like
24 grand daddy needs a new camshaft
i don't even know what those do really
your checkpoint nine of 23.
that city does got lights
it's pretty it doesn't seem like the
biggest game world
but then
it's not very city-like as well like in
terms of like obviously they crafted
this to be a racing city so they're a
spectacular racing city yeah there's not
so many not many crosswalks
which is to be appreciated one one thing
that i hated about the crew
is that
there was
there's way too many things that stopped
you dead in your tracks
which this game seemed to have figured
that out it's like just don't put stuff
in the way yeah like don't worry about
oh cops
i love that effect
oh whoa you almost ate that guy
so i never saw a difficulty
setting
i haven't yet
but i don't know if
you get to choose how
hard you want to be on yourself
there was some like control stuff where
during drifts it said turn off stability
control okay
i would probably want because whenever
the game starts to control you during
drifts and stuff it's so annoying i'm
gonna try to like fix it for you did you
win right at the end nice work
you got another four grand
message new personal best nice work
uh square specs saying early access as
in like steam early access or you have
got early access before release man
the words they're just they're difficult
uh this is available so you can
literally go play this right now if you
want to as well it's on ea access which
is their
subscription service on the xbox one so
it's i think it's 4.99 a month and via
that you get like you know free ea games
which is usually something like mirror's
edge and mercenaries
um the other the speed from last time oh
is that currently on there yeah okay um
and then you also get access to games
before launch for like demos so they've
done this with madden they've done it
with fifa and they're doing what need
for speed so we have basically got 10
hours
you can play this game for
excuse me
um yeah so you can
this is not a press thing this game is
out next week but you can literally like
uh get in on at least play the first 10
hours of this
or play the first hour 10 times if you
want to so yeah it's a time draw
basically
yeah and then i think you actually get a
discount
on the full game that you decide to
purchase oh really
part of your ea access actually you're
right yeah like all the ea games are
slightly i don't know how much it is
though
yeah probably
i'm out running the cop right now yeah
so this is after the race the copper
slapped you right yeah i guess so yeah
this guy's a
you gotta learn him like the last guy he
finds up to 2 000.
i do like the idea that you can just
like stop yeah whatever he's doing
oh oh oh
it's escalating all right whoa did you
did you just eat that car really i need
to take like a really
break
oh
dark it's dark
i like it holds out all the color
and the cops in play
the reflections
the water
it's dope and the environment as well i
wonder if you like just have to get like
off roads tonight oh no three of them
found me
yeah there's a real situation happening
here you're almost up to three thousand
dollar climb all right i'm gonna have to
go
into the neighborhoods
oh no get out of there get out of there
oh it's like giving me a camera angle i
can't it's like you're almost getting
arrested
dude that must be the end of that and
lilo124 says 10 discount on all the a
games and dlc yeah okay that's pretty
good yeah
it's not incredible but yeah you could
definitely earn earn that money back
that's your monthly fee i guess five
bucks right now yeah i think it's five i
think it's 4.99 might be five nine
i can't remember i'm i'm not very good
at budgeting so who [ __ ] knows how
much i've been i've been on this thing
for a year
just taking my money it's like i'm on
netflix not like like i live with my
girlfriend who also has netflix
yeah
yes i'm in a situation where i can't
cancel in my comcast because i have like
a deal and oh no now we have another so
i'm double pane oh you're kidding
nightmares nightmares for days um
game is super bright and choppy uh it's
kind of bright net and this is kind of
the regular color palette we have now
so the it's 30 frames yeah yeah and it
slows down like right there kind of
slowed down
did not work halloween
what a what a day today is huh is it
halloween today or saturday but
i don't even know what that is it's i'm
robert j hope it's jay
it's me
it's you ea access tell us ea access
what else can we expect from hot
i heard a noise in my ear and i was like
somebody's there with a mask i can just
tell
damn you
uh lots of love for the mid light club
series you know oh yeah it's been a
while since rockstar put out one of
those actually
all right let's go do something like
that uh mattenberg says latest free
games on ea access for xbox one or
dragon age inquisition and battlefield
hardline that's actually
that's pretty good should we let's do a
daily challenge what do we get yeah i do
look at that guy escape five or six no
those are kind of boring oh i forget
that guy's name style he is some
japanese street racer guy who is very
famous who i do not know cool so
somebody in chat party tell us
oh wait i already completed this good
job andy
no problem i'm killing that game
so one of the funny things is when you
go to the map your car just keeps going
okay so i just hope i don't run into
anything
somebody was saying if the subway
entrances are marked then you can
probably use those as shortcuts oh yeah
that's a good job you do teleport yeah
i mean
it's basically the game right here
yeah
run with your crew
you want to know why i do this you want
you i know why you i want to know you
don't there you go
ooh can you go in there hmm drive your
car in there
oh [ __ ] actually this is it it actually
says enter location get ready for an fmb
danny okay
hopefully
yes
i have the need for fmv
you think this is
a camera shot come on
please go in here we go yeah
we're on live
action i gotta turn up speakers out here
here we go look at that guys me mugging
you
look at this set dude
this is like in some sound stage you
know
they built this incredible set
that's my pool what does that mean is
that good uh i see how it is dog you're
so confident when we raise the stakes a
little huh call those lights in the back
no bar is lit this way
about four in the morning
don't be
wasting that college fine man where you
drive do you know any of these people
yeah they're all here well spike is the
guy with the hat he's the trust fund guy
okay um he's the guy that's like
bringing you in
this is the guy that called me and i
hung hung up on him on the left yeah
okay it just met him i'm not sure his
deal so when when's the moment when they
hand you a guitar and you go out and
stay to start playing
yeah
uh i think that's after the credits
like so close uh i'm not quite sure
about her she's just she's trying to get
you liquored up yeah
um and then there's another girl
who's your mechanic friend and she lets
you use her shop right now okay sorry
she's not interested not be slow do you
think magnus got what he is today by
taking it easy huh
no but then again and then there was
like this other sweaty guy who he met
okay you can tell he was maybe gonna be
the villain because he was all sweaty
i mean the guy on the left
this is pretty sweaty as well
maybe he's a little bit evil anybody
that's played the nba 2k story
i'm assuming this is the vic guy the guy
that everybody's like why are you
hanging out guys
he has like a tragic story spoilers no
spoilers
it was a bad vic all along i loved
hearing the giant beast take down
i hope i love it outrageous story in a
video game so i hope the need for speed
really leans into it like
wait is it like it's like almost morning
okay here we go everyone watch okay so
this is like about as close to daytime i
think as you get in this game
and you're just doing sick donuts i
don't know what i'm supposed to do what
was the resolution of that scene so this
looks yeah
okay
i don't know 7 20.
yeah so it looks like it's almost
daytime is it going to get dark again
look at the sun stay okay just like just
stay stay just like let's figure this
out we can figure out what's going on so
the sun's rising
i'm taking snapshots
are you you could take snapshots oh yeah
here we go okay i don't i don't care how
long we have to wait here
we're going to figure this out so i just
done this
yeah just getting ready
let's get hella red
so it's on the sun is like rising a
little bit
so
i wonder if it's gonna if it's like one
of these
it's just gonna kiss the horizon and go
back down again or something imagine if
it actually turned to daytime right now
yeah
all right check out the song where's the
song though
oh it looks like it's creeping down it's
already going back huh
all the birds are freaking out they're
like wait wait a second zen times
i love how there's a reflection of the
sun although i think it actually is
behind that mountain maybe we spent all
day in the bar
that cutscene was actually like 12 hours
you just wandered out again
is that because this kind of feels like
daytime this is like yes i love games
that are set like dusk and dawn oh yeah
well that's magic
all right you are destroying these tires
yeah it's okay i got it i can get new
ones i like all the dirt i got four
thousand dollars
all right let's do a race again
yeah do it i guess the the sun
set stuff is like a little bit maybe it
takes a bit longer than we think so
let's yeah let's powder around and see
how big is the map that's it
two
oh look at these locations the mountains
that's where you drift you know yeah
probably i'm guessing so it's these el
rey
southport
all right let's do a
let's run the sprint race with amy oh
wait here's the blue guy j dot oh no
oh no that's a part that's you
who's over there what's that red icon
are they they're all different dude yeah
or a person
it could be a girl sprint race
can teleport over there oh i should have
drove to see what the sunset did we'll
see
see what the loading does to it
then that cycle is based on your
location
says wired dynamite how does he know
that
he's got so much knowledge wait that's
okay it's like straight up night time
here that's terrifying do you think it's
like perpetual just dawn in some other
part like what the [ __ ] truman show [ __ ]
is going on here oh
well it is like live
let's heat things up
get ready to rip it up let's do it amy
i like amy she's more about the racing
less about the playing pool okay amy's
cool she likes to
work on the cars
she's in it for the love of the speed
she said i could use any tool in her
workshop as long as i put it back
which you know i'll forget to put a pool
back
she's going to get so
mad and then the gay man
let's find out game over yeah
gamespot review i believe will be up on
monday
monday and midnight
midnight tuesday okay so tuesday morning
monday midnight pacific so if you're in
europe that'll be like eight in the
morning or seven maybe because daylight
savings uh so super early tuesday
morning if you're on east coast like 5am
or something
am i supposed to beat them
or do they want me to just hang out with
them squarepixels wondering if this is
the
map from undercover i don't
imagine they'd take it wholesale but
apparently it looks pretty familiar they
have no recollection
yeah they all sort of bleed together for
me
at this stage
we keep playing them every single year
so it's
although it's been a lot it's been a
couple years i guess oh yeah take that
pedestrian yeah on your way home from
the late shift
sorry that was the part jerk just
rear-ends you
no nos for you i had an ass right now
i wouldn't have hit this before if you
yeah if you kept the knoss would stop
you from crashing in all these other
cars
you got it andy you had it inside of you
this is actually she's winning by a lot
she is i think it's going to bring
people whoa
that dude is totally right
what the f
okay
we need to remember this piece of road
and go back there
and figure out what the [ __ ] just
happened it just did the region i went
to like a new place that is truman show
right there
okay that's i've literally never seen
that in a video game before like except
when a bug happened suffering guitar
hero when you
switch from losing to winning
yeah exactly it's the same thing
well that was crazy
why is fall 2015 the year to bring back
weird fmv [ __ ]
and then make the game look like it was
shot
uncanny valley man
just over there are there any racing
games on ps4 that run at 60 frames a
second i don't think so drive club
doesn't project cars yeah sorry project
cars no it doesn't no it wasn't 160 does
it on console i don't think so i play on
pc i played it on the ps4 but i didn't
think it i don't remember i i i want to
say it does so forza does on xbox one
right yeah sports
motors yeah go back to where you were go
back down that
oh amy's calling
amy we just raced why do you gotta be so
clingy
maybe meet up please i looked away and
it looked like you were teleported to
later talk
no i don't think it is a bug spy door i
think that's
uh so who was it someone else in the
chat yeah someone else in the chat said
that it's locked to
yeah wired dynamite said he thinks it's
locked to the different regions so go on
the highways will probably take me to
the so it was this highway wasn't it
different boroughs yeah all right so
let's see what happens
the right way
yeah kind of
okay
it's so weird it doesn't pause when you
go into the map
yeah does it rain this game are the
roads just naturally wet for effect
well well all the cops actually when you
film stuff you gotta wet the road down
we haven't i've seen a raining but again
in specific areas like i wonder if all
the weather effects are tied to
the region you're in if it takes place
in california
it's completely unrealistic
and where are you going to pay the fine
yeah rb
wait did you just pay off that car
because i would pay the
yeah you're just like just like [ __ ]
they go he's 100 bucks see officer
is that the one yeah it is yeah you want
to get on that on-ramp yeah
white dynamite said he was in the beta
or they were in the beta and that's how
it worked i tried to get the beta
i didn't get it
it's like arkham knight it says julian
brewer is that the same cop you just
drove past the same cop
i wasn't even going that far night time
night time night time
and we're back tonight
that was a smoother transition yeah go
back the other way again all right
sorry
you're really fascinated by this i am
because when you went the other way it
just went [ __ ] daytime [ __ ] it
just popped up all right here we go
maybe i can lose the cops in the time
warp
i know you paid the fine but i love how
paying the fine is like oh yeah just day
that's so weird
uh that was more smooth than it happened
before yeah we were going faster zones
yeah you lost a couple through the time
war baby he's just paying the fine just
to be like ah those cops gotta get
gotta get paid somehow but it yeah it is
funny how like the cop then says to you
just mind you speeding
paying the fine so my car's not really
set up
for drifting but it feels not good for
drifting all right so maybe we should
try some drifting
what's that little camera down there on
the map i don't know it's a speed trap
maybe oh man
i mean burnett had a bunch of those as
well all right um also available on xbox
one right now
no as soon as the update comes out i
kind of like the idea of them doing the
the day-to-night stuff test
yeah i do drift contest to do this it's
you know it's unique like if okay fair
enough they don't want to have daytime
in the game because of it it offers them
like a reason why there's no traffic
it looks filmic yeah it looks good and
it's part of this whole
long night sort of vibe they're going
for
and i guess street racing does happen at
night like it makes sense
um it's yeah i guess it's just the
regions seem a little bit
that's i don't know
it seems i know you're not looking for
your realism and you're in your world
maybe necessarily in a driving game but
definitely
you know let's set up for drift i like
the idea of time passing time passing is
a like time passing in the phantom pain
is a really satisfying thing oh
that came for sure because you're like
oh it's daytime and then you're you
finish the level it's nice and you
realize like oh wow i've spent like time
doing this
the camera is a screenshot location not
a speed trap so is that where you did
you press a button for that
it's probably just like hey this is a
cool spot to take a picture
uh julian buffett wants to see burford
wants to see some tuning all right
so this one gives you like an overall
right um
but you can but it does do granular
stuff which is cool so on the top part
you can basically do it all and then go
down good energy so here's some tire
pressure
i don't see your response so if you if
you change that that will also change
the top one
yeah
yeah it gives you an idea of what you're
adjusting
brake assist off
off
who's breaking drift assist i don't know
says
possibility to initiate a breaking trip
turn this off triggers as possible
so that's more like
it just does it for you i guess
it's kind of weird so i guess i have to
upgrade parts to get your diff and
everything else yeah
so it's good i guess they give the
option for
you know enthusiasts to get into the
nitty-gritty um you know change the
front and rear tires and all that stuff
and then also for the sort of amateur
play style they just have that straight
up handling
like
bar which can just do us all in one go
for you if needs be so
okay
um what else is in here actually yeah
let's get some more parts let's get some
drift parts you got all that money from
racing we got tons of money 24 g's can i
have a turbo charger yet i can sick
so put a turbo and a brz which i don't
know how i feel about that
i don't know you want all the power up
front though for drifting right i don't
really know how drifting works hmm
that'll be better for
immediate power because i don't have to
spool up on the rpg into the engine
that's good
yeah we'll get a better exhaust if we
can a good question from gaming hobo is
there any censorship on decals like no
dick pics
i don't know i haven't it hadn't
unlocked earlier right like you couldn't
do any of the visual stuff we'll check
in a second i want tighter suspension
but i can't all right we can get drift
tires though
cool yeah you burned out the other ones
can i get better brakes yet not yet 21.
all right oh yeah so what level you're
six already yeah wow okay it's going up
alright yeah
who wouldn't have been playing for the
you know best part of 40 minutes or
something oh i'm not gonna
competition all right show us some of
the some of the visual stuff as well
okay let's see if i can do more
customization
yeah you may have to i did my hood
that's one i can do okay
that's some sick carbon fiber intakes
yeah
some hood scoops what else we got
still all locked front bumper i can
change bumpers
but then it is locked to the car i guess
oh yeah so it's weird that you do some
tuning here too
so i like
you want to be low for more
stability
so maybe we have to do the first mission
of the style stuff to get into more of
this oh let's do one of those then in a
little while maybe that unlocks after
that so let's yeah we might get to that
after this bit
confirmed can you paint on the car like
you can't afford so we know there's some
aspect of that but i can't find it um it
might be locked but this is just all
hard points so it's like fender
bumper oh wow so you straight up can't
do that stuff until
i don't know i can change them overnight
because you've leveled up to be able to
change the bumper okay let's do that
it's cool so is this definitely the the
the final game no no the this section
back out a second what's it called
visual customization that sounds like
that would be the painting yeah but i
can't find a spot to do it i've looked
for a while
like you're not even changing how the
skirts look you're actually changing the
skirts
yeah so it's not like you're even
changing the paint or you can there
might be a different shop i have to go
to or something weird
okay a little bit strange if there's not
so much there anyway
yeah i agree i wanted to change the
color
uh this is not available on ps4 yet this
is only available at the moment via ea
access which is the subscription service
available on xbox one
yeah all right let's go do the drift
pixel guy says same old auto tune
lame hoods from the older games that's
the tsunami hood
painting is on the menu option before
that one all right so he's back out and
have a look at that
keep your eyes peeled
johnny michael spotted it
i go he's always spotting it
okay are they gonna show that every
single time he pulled out of that card
all right yes
straight in yeah back and see if we can
get into that again
all right just to see the
jump back to the garage yeah
just uh
since we're since we're doing it hashtag
how to rep
i should look up hashtag header right
now donuts
toony ray okay so it's here maybe
what's over to the side is that like
another car oh wait
purchase car you can purchase another
car right now
yeah i can buy cars
click on it that's what we got i don't
know if money do oh i do have money i
got that sick
[ __ ] gti
mustang that's about where i run out
what's
what's the top level oh so it doesn't
show you anything that you can't afford
yet or what does yeah just
these are all out of my range so far
what's the craziest car you can buy
dodge challenger 25 000 are all the same
car these three
yeah but i already own that one gave me
a freebie at the front
you got to pick which one you wanted at
the start uh yeah out of
the brz
the
honda
this one
and civic i think that one or the ford i
don't okay
anyway
all right that makes that's good
oh yeah that'd be a good drift car
what's the most expensive car we have
probably a porsche
because ea owns the license to porsche
exclusively oh really you're there
there's a 911 45. oh lotus that that's a
good car
yeah
and two oh ford focus
58 thousand dollar car okay
uh 911 carrera
corvette oh gtr premium that's oh yeah
here we go
a viper man i [ __ ] love those vipers
in the old 70s gran turismos
oh it came in gt that's like a brand new
portion it's [ __ ] amazing so is the
that one as well yeah
oh 458 that's cool
the new all right now we're getting some
real stuff now yeah here's the superglue
broken
that's a
hyper car hyper car
yeah we're going to see a huayra in here
as well or something yeah
the classic
classic ferrari f40 it's like the first
hyper car wow
wait is that the top one let's uh you
know what if you're gonna have a top car
yeah a ferrari f40 is a pretty good ship
it's such a cool car yeah i used to have
a model of that bad boy dude play that
in forza horizon
oh is it in horizon yeah wow it's so
good uh 40s 40s beautiful that's class
all right incoming
so where was the where's the painting
though
yeah so go into the car
yeah hey on the car use a breather
and a it was here so we said we went in
visual what's the one over to the right
tuning
you know performance the whole crew
together will be good
that's all
i don't know
maybe this is it i just can't do it
unavailable
let's just go back and let's fix them
again
yeah what's going on with what's going
on with matt let's do this drift thing
now that i've set up go in the car is
under the wraps menu
yeah whatever we'll do there
the one that looks like a sheet of paper
is that unavailable it said unavailable
so i think we have to do the first
mission
with manu oh one thing of note is it's
using the trigger buzzes in the xbox one
controller which is cool oh cool
the feedback yeah
all right where's manny at
well i wanna do the drift one
oh yeah
you can always fast travel yeah el rey
is that it yeah that was it
get it done boom teleportation
teleport into daytime land oh if you
sync your drift you earn more rep what
does that even mean
if you drift alongside somebody yeah if
you do like a
same drift at the same time you're an
urban outlaw man it says it on the car
wait where you going where you going
where are you going oh yeah i forgot i
had to like
activate it i was just into the sound of
my supercharger oh yeah
yeah that's going to really piss off
your neighbors
turn around to start event this game is
very particular
call these boats
rb baby all right x dreamer is currently
number one on the speed wall
controller's freaking out right now
all right daniel corbius
and irma
great names i love that some people just
have one name
and some have like first and second
names that are very complicated
how does the driving feel good question
easy it's a kill it's a kyle kyle's it's
super easy like uh how do i explain it
in the realm of arcade simulation does
it feel like are we talking does it feel
like only for speed games it doesn't
feel like forza right this is not a
it doesn't feel like you're driving a
performance car
feels like you're playing a video game
if that makes sense so turning is easy
yeah
i'm really losing this one
and i'm doing sick drifts
like you're over drifting pretty hard as
well
it doesn't seem like you need to drift
at all to take these turns
no
are you pulling the e-brake though is it
only not on all of them but
that's like key drifting
there you go i got a little bit oh
drifting x1 look at all the points
you're getting me
oh yeah it doesn't matter if it's speed
it's mostly it's all the drift points
you want to get oh i'm pretty sure
you're killing it right now on my
account as well i really appreciate it
no problem that's why we set up for
drifting exxon 3 adx gamer
3rx says so excited for this game been
waiting two years oh nice the jersey is
fun
is it
yeah
now that we're in like a more tuned
drift setup i i like it
does the car feel a little bit different
after doing all that stuff oh yeah for
sure
that's always good to know so
at least you know you're not stuck with
the
defaults
i can't wait to play one of those
supercars that
those fields by the
top top dog
julian burford says i've driven
at 40 some years ago fun fact the door
handles inside is just a piece of hard
rope you have to pull on to open it yeah
what
nothing but speed that's beautiful
yeah rope man rope makes it light i got
first but i was definitely not like
ahead of the race
i guess it was just gorbachev
so you're running that's that hoon again
hunan
hunan you want to know you're already up
to halfway through level seven yeah the
leveling is definitely very fast
way to initiate those corners
is that what you said yeah you initiated
the crop out of those corners on me
all right let's see if uh
who's that dude again
let's see if he's got a mish yeah
on where is he shown
see in the mission
question mark oh there he is green
that's speed isn't it oh wait you're
right yellow yeah
style
that means he probably likes drifting
his style it's his favorite taylor swift
song mine too man
yeah
you never go out of style got that red
red lipstick yeah yeah do you think
mano's got a short turn he's got
yeah
the tight little skirt
let's find out oh he's at the top oh
please be another cutscene please be
another cutscene oh [ __ ] yeah
look at that fake car in this real oh no
that's awesome
is this daytime i can't tell there's a
huge hmi outside that window
there's not man
it says who
you
come on amy back me up this is your crew
love it i like amy's hair it hurts me
she's got them almost like that
going on shotgun enough grease on her in
a rush well you know holding it at that
point
all right okay i'm out of here look at
that guy's hair coming yeah
i wish i could do that [ __ ] with my hair
peace
this piece bro does that connect does
that connect you got to put your fist up
yeah
they drink a lot of monsters in this
game do they is are they drinking
monster right now hey man they're racing
all night of course they're drinking
monsters yeah for one reason only
he sucks at it awesome product placement
you need a certain finesse
to hold that slide or whomever position
it's all about riding the tipping point
this guy's got some sunken eyes
you never wrong he's seen some stuff
look i get it apples and oranges you
know
ah
you see
robin here
she's got class got that steady hand hmm
spike
he be yanking on the e-brake like a
teenager fresh out of driver's head
come on he's not that bad man it's just
a good thing this is actually kind of
like well
i played that whole living the dream
yeah but just because i wanted to you've
had enough
little noisy chaos all right see you
later lindsay lohan standing
later
honestly what's up with the hair can you
teach me that end of the curve i don't
care about the car stuff right now this
stuff just happened when she's around
you know
wait what was eating either way pie
i wish i had pie right now i'm smoking
rubble with a bench or a base set i
don't really want a monster but i want a
pie now
i'll complete some pie sponsorship
getting some money for the local scene
three calendars
the next hot video game
esports team
well that was fun i think it's just
coffee that reminded me the first scene
in fahrenheit remember that indigo
prophecy oh yeah um fahrenheit yeah it
was called fahrenheit in europe
all right so what are you gonna do now
amy
you gotta give me a call but i didn't
answer is there a finesse situation or
can you now go to your garage and do
[ __ ] to your car
no just a spike
check my messages hold up
oh show us your phone check our messages
i love a good fake phone in a video game
outlaw
called cop baiting
that's a bit dark
yeah
hey what's up what's up
hey
we're running on xbox one right now
all right let's do it amy we'll do
another
yeah i'd love some pumpkin pie with ice
cream too mastered the hero oh pumpkin
pie still kid it's almost that time of
year it is that time yeah everything's
pumpkin right now
don't forget guys the deluxe edition is
only ten bucks more it says ward dog
zero zero what do you get you get like
cars you probably get a bunch of dlc
might not ever play
uh or you can you can play this right
now if you want on the access if you're
signed up it's only 4.99 a month
well i want to say only for a month i've
been on it for about a year i'm not
really sure how much i've used it but
um if you subscribe right now you get in
on this madness you get to play never
speed for
10 hours timed demo which is currently
what we're doing so
this is uh available to you if you want
as well see you amy yes now that i've
got upgraded like a supercharger going
oh yeah
um
slayer 3k wants to know this deluxe
version come with better haircuts
i imagine you customize the haircuts
and they like shot the scene exactly oh
my god that'll be appalling over and
over
yeah like there's like 50 different
types
i just kept having to do it over and
over again
yeah you could change the like gender
and ethnicity of everyone in the scene
and it plays out so do you think david
cage is looking at all this stuff
and going no no no no
like i've been doing it all wrong or is
he like man maybe i should consider just
doing it that way
and like blending the gameplay with the
fmv i think he's saying
no
no no no no no no no
that's not how you do it
you must get the emotions and then shoot
it every game needs a digital version of
[ __ ] development
exactly literally what i was thinking of
digital will default you play your lars
von trier video game
uh limited edition comes with a
steelbook car part whoa really and the
need for speed most wanted bmw and extra
stickers according to big drifter two
one zero someone gave me rockstar
valve caps
oh really that's how they found in the
office i still haven't put them on my
car yet sure lilo124 mentions that you
can also get ea access for 30 a year
which is most certainly a better deal
um than the madness i'm paying for which
would end up being 60 so yeah
for sure
i sure wish there was manual shifting
but there was one thing that has changed
my driving and racing games and for the
better is learning how to
just manual shift yeah it's easy in real
life but like in the game
it took me a while to
get used to my own [ __ ] it no just like
to want to do it once you do it you like
get it real quick for sure and it's way
better
especially in driving because you're
shifting so much yeah and you way more
extra power band and you want to stay in
the power band
yeah so it feels like it's almost like
active reload when you get good at it
it's like it's got that satisfaction of
bam bam like hitting the right moment
and feeling when the engine's like
struggling a little bit you got to hold
back and then
that's
yeah once you once you kind of do it
it's hard to go back i think the new
controllers are way better at like
allowing you to know when you're in your
high range as well oh yeah so like
like i think
forza was the first game where i enjoyed
doing manual shifting forwards on xbox
one yeah with a controller because like
with a steering wheel it's fine but like
with a controller i never really felt
like i was in touch with the engine
whereas with those it definitely does
forza has a clutch if you want and i was
like no oh yeah that would be
another level like it's easy in the car
but it's not [ __ ]
and gaming hallways does this game use
the trigger rumble in the xbox one
controller and that's cool that it does
sure it's not a lot of third-party stuff
does the roads ever dry out how's the
weather and
in the game like
does it change throughout each place it
seems like we can we don't know first of
all because we haven't playing enough
but it does seem like the weather and
the
the time is based on each region
like it was raining in there a second
ago and it looks like it's now not
raining because you're leaving yeah i'm
also being chased by a car
you are
this coffee was
accidental
this car this company wants 655 dollar
bribe
ooh spontaneous do i want to do that how
do they
i don't know you could spontaneously get
a challenge
oh let's go
oh am i going to get arrested oh yeah
busted busted what happened all right
why you pressed past what was it you got
to spend
i just fine he just does the fine is it
fine i think it was an extra 500 on top
of what your vine was okay
or maybe it's amazing it's gonna load me
it's probably gonna do a cutscene at the
jail
wouldn't that be cool
driving out of jail
oh no we're back here busted what a drag
uh go in and see if you can do the
customization stuff now
oh yeah
no i'm still unavailable [ __ ]
damn it
i got new parts it doesn't matter
sick i want to change the well i want
you to go to a turbo charger
just
i don't know because
at kb 2297 does this feel like the old
undergrounds might be a bit of a stretch
to remember back that far but does it
feel like a classic knee for speed feel
like i don't remember what that seems
like it does from
i guess it's it's so nuanced maybe it's
a bit of a
stretch to say that but it definitely
is handling like a need for speed game
our review will be up on monday
um
yes they definitely do have a strange
justice system laser jock
probably earns him a lot of money though
so yeah
a lot of underground fans it definitely
feels like an underground game like it
feels like part of that series i don't
haven't put a
subtitle on it but like this is
basically an underground game
what's up
let us paint our car
stop being a jerk
oh mission marked here we go manu style
manu manu he's all about that style
yeah dude that's teleport gotta go check
out manu on a sick hair
problem
that last phrase felt like it just let
me win at the end oh really
can you use the elite controller pads
for shifting uh no
i don't think so we have we should go
get the elite controller i was actually
just thinking you don't think uganda
i don't think there is any shifting
oh yeah there is no shifting you're
right you were looking at the options
and it seemed to
suggest that there was none yeah the way
the elite
maybe you can unlock it if you upgrade
your parts i should try that but in the
control like menu it doesn't even have
an indication that you can do that like
automatic command doesn't allow you to
doesn't even say yeah and it doesn't
even say like shift that [ __ ] down
all right so this is another drifting
style situation okay
so i guess by style he's talking about
racing style wow it hitched up pretty
bad there a second ago the frame rate
did i think someone was connecting oh
really yeah all right
yeah whatever just like yeah random ass
drift
sorry
you just killed that guy
man you're already beating manu
oh you got no points there
get that draft yeah
all right
you're backing first
oh no
if i chain my if i not chain it but
coordinate my drift that's what i want
to do
oh let's give it a show shall we here we
go here we go
just like cut the corner yeah it was a
really good night at a good turn you're
in second place but you're close oh whoa
thanks tommy
that actually worked and now you've just
got two thousand out of that you're in
first again
drifting's always been weird in these
games
it's such like a like there's definitely
a white way to drift like i've been to
drift competitions and there are like
ways of doing yeah take that manu um but
like a lot of it is still subjective so
it's i feel like games never really
like you shouldn't get points if you
drift and then ram into someone
yes you lose all your points
yeah
you're winning
oh manic just got a big one off that
turn that was a good left to right one i
didn't need to connect
oh let's stop
it's all getting ready it's all getting
ready for this one
did you win it you got first how's that
impossible is this easy i didn't do
anything i there must be a way to make
this harder
any online races available yet do you
know well there are people in our game
yeah
um and there's certainly
you did try and race them and they were
right
yeah they didn't want to
crew play
the crew is in this game as well it's
your crew who else is playing
team up and drive together
i don't think any of my
friends don't know
manny's back manny what's up dog
it'll get harder the further you
progress as master the hero there will
be medium and hard challenges later oh
cool
seems like they are pretty easy though
i guess they want to keep you winning at
the start of a video game right
do you think any any last mission we can
do or something yeah let's do
do one more you picky pick your poison
bro let's
let's drive your new car
let's buy a car you're gonna buy a car
yeah i wonder if they'll let you paint
this one yeah maybe
all right buy a ferrari f40 i can't
make can we microtransaction our way to
f40
that's actually a good question come on
ea
i mean it is the a game right 27 okay
that's a good let's see let's get the
highest card we can it's our one we
already own
um
damn it really oh no you you're just shy
for the challenger that sucks i don't
want to drive a challenger
okay
[ __ ] you though it's like [ __ ] the
crew all over again
let's do this on tour super
yeah look at our fast and furious one on
purchase complete you're just filling
out the paperwork
all right here we go
i like the
nice lighting effects up in there yeah
still can't mess with the paint job
sadly
well we're gonna need
we're gonna need us to turbo charger
bring a new tire
nice
can i get
oh yeah
incredible oh can i buy nitrous yet oh i
can you can buy an os for this
yeah yeah oh wow look i'm running wait
i'm running out of money
by the 5000 one or the five pound one
let's get a new exhaust
make it sound real dirty
all right all right we got two ground
left man all right we'll spend it on the
turbo
oh no
insufficient funds are turbocharged
really that expensive crap all right
it's fine it'd be better for drifting
without the turbo lag
sick brakes well i like that effect a
lot
let's do it i think the lens
popped on all right let's see your
your nos
i really want to change the color but
you can't do that yet because reasons we
don't know
because of important video game reasons
yeah we got nitrous now
uh the painting might be closed for
other reasons i played with this car on
the beta and i could change the painting
maybe it's just the trial thing
yeah maybe maybe we don't know if this
is like how representative of the full
game this really is actually oh i like
this
oh hefty doughboy hey you want to play
yeah
he's beeping
i don't know how
oh he's doing it doing journey we're
doing journey
use your nos
there we go whoa
we got purple
whoa did you challenge him no
he's not oh robin's challenging me
hey you i think he died
nothing too serious
hold on i should've done nothing what's
going on oh yeah
are they on a conference call what's
going on
on your side of
talking about
up at some point all right let's need
doing
meeting
for speed i think andy no more mission
you want one more mission but the supra
all right i trust you twice about
throwing around they're still having a
conversation
you've got a lot of things now you've
got speed crew style build outlaw i want
rob and brace
where's she at though i'll catch y'all
on flip later i like outlaws you just
have to get cops to chase you for two
minutes and then escape that's pretty
good
uh are these the same missions as we've
already done let's do another one
all right another drift one
event's kicking off all over town
tonight the endless night of need for
speed get out 2015. some of that
yeah this game is only night time it's
kind of weird kind of like it bills
trial
it's the tariq two step
whoa
the controller's just freaking out
you go bye-bye tires oh no
yeah
right
all right let us know when you're using
the nostalgia i'm using lost okay
purple purple purple
you know how long the last for like
three seconds in yeah there's a little
container in the bottom
there's a cage
i don't think i have this set up as nice
as that no it looks like so that's good
at least to know that like yes you
cars yeah they are like
working differently this cob is not
happy
like i know that license plate you have
that on all your cars
605 oh you already got away from
good job oh i better use my knife
oh yeah so you got nitrous then adrift
that's crazy
got 140 rep for that
a cop went and told his buddies and i
got word around the street
here we go big drift
yeah this car is not as set up for it
it's actually real good at making 90
degree turns it turns out it's just
super good
180s
that's highly unrealistic what was that
driving game where you could just hit
orbee and lb and you do like you just do
the turn yeah
is it like a ridge racer or something
mario kart
oh
it's a popo again i gotta get you this
time ghost
ghost
you are you're gonna ghost him in a
second
cool down
he did that
good job
all right 750 bucks
you've only got five checkpoints
checked out four checkpoints left
you're going to show your cops some sick
drifts yeah it's around them
let's go
i really miss the drift setup now you
miss your old car that you could do that
well it's good to know it's a little bit
more substantive than
some other games related to that stuff
like it's not full on simmer anything
but it is good to know that oh here we
go he's got his body
where's
korean jesus now
nice work you did it
is this five hundred dollars what do you
got yeah like four grand for the races
yeah this one's uh
harder i guess damn
better get some more
all right you're level nine already and
the cops are still hating you
all right well there's only like
10 minutes left on our ea access
i think we've got like seven hours
10 10 in total yeah
but yeah that's us we're done thank you
so much for hanging out that was need
for speed
available i guess next week next tuesday
our review will be live on gamespot.com
midnight monday that's pacific time so
if you're on the east coast that's like
whatever let's say three four in the
morning uh five in the morning or if
you're in uk time uh europe it'll be for
breakfast uh thanks so much andy for
driving around the wonderful terrifying
living nightmare that is nighttime town
need for speed you bet uh and thanks
very much for watching thanks eric tay
for running production in the back and
for more now playings and coverage of
drifting games and beyond stay tuned to
gamespot.com see you next time
you